[Aplausos]
muchos viajes
viajamos me incluyo vale me incluyo
cada vez que escucho a alguien viajar 6
vosotros o sea cualquier otra persona me
pregunto qué es lo primero en lo que os
fijáis que es lo primero que buscáis
cuando vais de viaje trabajo descanso un
cambio así de atmósfera o incluso sitio
para vivir vale sin embargo
quiero haceros saber que hay un
beneficio muy grande en esta actividad
que es el aprendizaje y no no me refiero
al aprendizaje de culturas y de ser
abierto de mente porque eso ya lo
sabemos todos o espero que lo sepáis al
menos hablo del aprendizaje del colegio
si colegio secundaria bachillerato
universidad etcétera en fin
porque estoy hablando de el aprendizaje
académico siento que aparte de ser
cultural el colegio ha formado parte de
nuestras vidas y entonces pues siento
que tiene una gran importancia y pienso
que se puede relacionar con los viajes
la pregunta es como que tiene que ver
viajar con estudiar no tiene sentido
verdad ahora es lo explico
llena lo académico no podemos negar que
a todos alguna vez nos ha tocado estar
en verano sentados en la mesa haciendo
los deberes de repaso que nos ponen las
20 hojas de matemáticas cuántos de
vosotros os habéis dicho qué aburrido no
estará ahí sentado si como veis hay
bastante gente que se aburrido a ver no
hay que negar que es importante aprender
lo que
en plan repasar lo que hemos aprendido
sin embargo es la única forma de hacerlo
o podemos buscar una forma más
interactiva
productiva
atractiva y enganchan te por así decirlo
a los estudiantes bueno para eso podemos
aprovechar los viajes
depende de lo que queráis aprender a ver
se puede aprender muchas cosas
en idiomas eventos históricos entre
otros según lo que queráis aprender
recurrir es a una cosa u otra eso es lo
bueno de los viajes que hay muchas
variedades y muchos sitios a los que se
puede ir por ejemplo supongamos que
habéis estado aprendiendo un idioma
durante mucho tiempo vamos a poner
alemán vale qué mejor forma de aprender
el idioma o si ya tenéis cierto nivel
mejorar lo que ir al país donde hablan
en este caso alemania y hablarlo con esa
persona con nativo parlantes así de paso
os hacéis algunos amigos si nos dejamos
de tanto online de tanto amiguito online
y mejor conocer una persona bueno no me
desvío también se puede aprender que se
puede aprender historia vale a muchos
nos aburre historia vale no nos vamos a
engañar muchas veces nos dormimos en
clase de historia perdón a los que les
gusta esta asignatura o perdón a los
profesores
como se puede aprender de una forma más
interactiva bueno hay bastantes sitios
como pueden ser teatros museos
exhibiciones no la de harry potter por
supuesto eventos
etcétera vale os voy a contar una algo
que hacía yo antes que era [ __ ] una
libretita pequeñita no muy grande
iba un museo tomaba apuntes y después
cuando volvía a mi caso de viaje pues
buscaba información sobre ello y gracias
a eso aprendí que los primeros el primer
tranvía en finlandia me refiero tranvía
de cabina como conocemos hoy en día se
creó en 1950 es un dato aleatorio un
dato un poco suelto que no viene mucho
en esta conversación pero sin embargo
aquí lo que estamos buscando no es el
simple dato la siento información
estamos buscando la forma de enganchar a
los estudiantes aprender de una forma
más interactiva como si estuvieran
viviendo dentro del aprendizaje me
entendéis
bueno está esto de viajar también lleva
un segundo beneficio que es socialmente
ahora cuántos de nosotros nos hemos
encontrado una situación de aprieto en
nuestra vida del día a día
vale ya estoy viendo bastantes personas
levantar sus manos tímidamente bueno
esto puede ayudarnos bastante y la
pregunta es seguro que os estáis
preguntando pero no es más fácil
enfrentarme una situación de mi día a
día con mis familiares o con los amigos
con los que siempre hablo sea el colegio
o instituto
claro es que eso es más fácil obviamente
y ese es el problema que no nos abrimos
no abrimos nuestras mentes hacia nuevos
dilemas nuevas situaciones que se nos
pueden presentar en un futuro vale que
tienen que ver los viajes en esto bueno
no es lo mismo evidentemente que se te
pierda la maleta en un aeropuerto al que
tanto estás acostumbrado a ir que en uno
o en un sitio que no que no conoce eso
que has viajado muy poco entendido bueno
os voy a hacer para que lo entendáis
mejor es voy a hacer una clase así
rápida de biología vale nuestro sistema
inmunológico es nuestro sistema de
defensa vale nos ayuda un montón a
defendernos contra las enfermedades
como lo hace muy simple
enfermedad y decide atacar nuestro
cuerpo que hace nuestro sistema pues
enfrentarse a ella por primera vez por
eso nos ponemos enfermos es normal vale
sin embargo cuándo vuelve esta
enfermedad a atacarnos nuestro cuerpo ya
sabe cómo reaccionar y dice oh mira esta
es esta enfermedad ya sabemos cómo
enfrentarnos entendido bueno por esta
razón pienso que se puede comparar a los
humanos que somos seres muy adaptables
vale y pienso que abriendo mucho
nuestras mentes tanto académicamente
como socialmente podemos tenemos la
capacidad de enfrentarnos a nuevas
situaciones
vale tanto académicamente como
socialmente por eso lo he incluido en
esta charla y antes de terminar me
gustaría saber cuántos de vosotros vais
de viaje este verano sea por españa o no
levantar la mano a ver
es bastante gente de la que yo me
imaginaba vale a pesar de el coronavirus
hay bastante gente que viaja y me alegra
saberlo porque así podéis aplicar el
conocimiento adquirido en esta charla
tanto académico para vuestros hijos y no
se aburran en verano como para los
adultos de tener una experiencia con su
familia y enfrentarnos a situaciones
nuevas en la vida muchas gracias por
escuchar mi charla y nos vemos en el
próximo viaje
[Aplausos]